do you remember when you came out to
your mother yes I came out when she kept
insisting that my friend was my best
friend to this day Adriana was so pretty
she was like
she's really pretty she is really pretty
yeah uh unbeknownst to my mother Adriana
is queer lesbian and I was like yeah
she's really beautiful and she's like
she has no boyfriend I was like no I
don't think so I don't think she's no no
she doesn't and it's not my place to
tell us how old were you at this point
this is high school high school this
High School this is like sophomore in
high school Maybe Junior and my mom
always knew but she never officially had
an answer or a a sentence or a quote for
me to to validate what her hunts or her
you know yeah uh and so it was weird
because I knew she knew how did you know
she knew I think a mother always knows
you know like I think it's just like and
I think me singing show tunes uh you
know at our Gatherings that's true and I
don't want to like you know categorize
you know know people who sing shot but
like I think I was always free in my
being that like I thought she knew
because I was always accused of it by
others was that hard it was hard because
she always would have to put up with
that like you know one of my my
um traumatic memories of knowing that I
was different and knowing that it was
because I was queer was because I was in
Mexico with my Tonka truck which I like
playing with Tonka trucks very manly
very boy yeah but also had dolls and so
yeah dolls and he had Tonka trucks and
then people are like what's going on
here you know and it's just like playing
with my Tonka track oh so play with my
doll you know I'm just like
um boys don't play with like I remember
having a conversation with like the
local kids where my grandma's like you
know Ranch thing was and it was like
they could tell
that I was just myself and for some
reason that was threatening and it was
weird because it was different and I
just always loved playing and make
believe and so I remember like I was
trying to play trucks with these boys
and then like we can't play trucks with
you because my brother says you're a
Mariposa what's that mean my brother
says you're a butterfly which is a
derogatory way of saying you're you're
gay
um
and that I'd understand it and I was
like Mariposa I was like they're
beautiful what's wrong with them I
didn't know what the negative
connotation to Mariposa was at that age
because pretty young and so they were
saying it over and over and I was like
what do you what like I and then I knew
it was bad and it was bad because I felt
it and I felt that it felt bad to be
this because you don't like getting you
don't like me being this and it was like
they kept chanting it
and I was like why do you want to play
with you anyways and I grabbed my Tonka
truck and I walked away and they kept
chanting it over and this and then I
felt something fly to the side of my ear
and then I turned around and just like
rocks flying towards me and one of them
hit me right here where I have the scar
and I just remember like gash my face
and just blood gushing over my face and
I just remember crying and running with
my truck and I dropped my truck and they
kept chanting the word and I was just
covered in jerks I found the dirt now
it's dirt and mud on my face Lord like
became like mud with the blood in the
sand and there's just like dirt all over
writing to my mom
screaming I was like
okay
and my mom just looked at me and then
she said
who cares that they call divided by
butterflies are beautiful
and I just remember thinking it was okay
but I know she was making me feel better
and she was making me feel better about
what I was so I knew she knew at that
moment either that age because she would
always protecting me from people like
that because I grew up in a very
machismo you know environment and
culture
um unfortunately our culture is very
much useful you know and it was uh it
was heartbreaking because I knew that
she was fighting the fight for me but it
was like I think that moment when I came
out it was more to tell her officially
like she kept hinting it she just wanted
me to say it and she basically said I
was like yeah it's really pretty nothing
to know
maybe you can be her boyfriend I was
like Mom you know I'm queer right and
she goes
I don't care as long as you're happy she
just wanted to hear it she just wanted
to hear it I think for her sake so we
can actually put that to rest but I
think it was it went without saying